[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue vous
vous en doutez on va beaucoup parler du
remaniement dans cette émission ils vont
occuper une bonne partie alors participé
donnez nous votre avis sur les entrants
sur christophe castaner sur l'opération
politique réussie ou non on va en parler
pour emmanuel macron qui s'adressera
d'ailleurs ce soir aux français
puis nous débattrons de cet autre
événement politique du jour le barouf le
mot n'est pas trop fort fait par jean
luc mélenchon et la france a soumise
après les perquisitions ce matin dans le
cadre d' enquête judiciaire
vous l'entendrez si ce n'est déjà fait
le patron de la france insoumise crie au
complot traite le pouvoir de tous les
noms
la cuisse d'un coup de force à se
demander s'ils ne se sont pas lui et ses
troupes qui sont à la limite du coup de
force
enfin il sera question d'une femme
mystérieuse qui a su se faire apprécier
du couple macron elle règne sur la
presse people mais elle a aussi ses
entrées à l'elysée
elle a su se rendre indispensable auprès
de brigitte macron elles s'appellent
mimi marchand et fait l'objet d'une
enquête très fouillée dans un livre qui
paraît demain nous en parlerons en avant
première bonjour olivier duhamel content
de le retrouver aujourd'hui pour
commenter ce remaniement enfin vous êtes
politologue vous présidez la fondation
nationale des sciences politiques
vous allez peut-être ajouter le mot
remaniement à la prochaine édition de
votre livre les mots de macron paru chez
dalloz et pour ceux qui ne le font pas
encore on ne peut que leur conseiller de
vous écouter le samedi matin sur europe
1 pour l'émission médiapolis que vous
animez bonjour benoît tisserand dit
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes historien vous enseigner l'histoire
en classes préparatoires et vous allez
sans doute nous aider à prendre un peu
de hauteur sur ce remaniement
bonjour et avoine le nord au sultan
stratégie membre du conseil scientifique
de la fondation et pour l'innovation
politique et professeur à sciences po
vous avez travaillé avec jacques attali
avec claude bébéar et vous avez écrit la
france des opportunités toutes les
bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne vous dit pas
si par nos belles lettres
exactement il jouera l'ex directeur des
rédactions du figaro le figaro qui
consacre demain sa page à ce remaniement
et puis évidemment vous trouvez déjà des
articles des vidéos sur notre site sur
ce sujet alors ça y est c'est fait
quinze jours après la démission de
gérard collomb on connaît le visage du
nouveau gouvernement
huit nouveaux cas de départ il y à une
dose de modems un petit pied de nez à la
droite
l'arrivée d'un valls east nous allons
passer tout cela au crible mais d'abord
on s'arrête sur la tête d'affiche
christophe castaner à l'intérieur il en
rêvait macron l'a fait on écoute le
nouveau mise de l'intérieur c'était lors
de la passation de pouvoir tout à
l'heure au moment d'accepter cette
proposition
on s'interroge on s'interroge sur la
responsabilité qui est celle du ministre
de l'intérieur
on s'interroge sur la capacité à assumer
cette fonction
et très vite on se rassure on se rassure
parce que ce ministère est à la tête de
trois cent mille femmes sommes
totalement engagés sur sa capacité à
assumer cette fonction
un bon choix oui pourquoi pas c'est de
voir comment je peux me hisser à la
hauteur de vous avez dit qu'elle
relevait plutôt d'un autre invité donc
c'est compliqué mais je pense que c'est
pas un mauvais choix parce que c'est un
élu de terrain et que c'est très
important particulièrement à ce
ministère de mettre un élu c'est un bon
choix parce que c'est pas idiot de
tenter un binôme avec un
un super flic entre guillemets et un
super politique puisque d'une certaine
manière qu as tu as l'air c'est quand
même un super politique je dire si c'est
une des grosses pointures socialiste qui
rejoint emmanuel macron il était très il
s'est fait élire parfois dans des
conditions assez difficiles dans le sud
est donc pour toutes ces raisons là je
pense que c'est un assez bon choix
alexis un épouvantail facile pour la
droite christophe castaner il ya
plusieurs façons d'analyser cette
affaire de castanet un voyageur comme
quelque chose d'assez 30 ans et qu'il
fallait quinze jours pour arriver à
castaner qui était quand même
effectivement le choix maintenant le
choix de la fidélité parce que le
premier la première raison pour un
présent avec dû choisir un militaire
c'est ce qui me sera fidèle
est ce que je peux lui faire confiance
et de ce point de vue c'est de toute
évidence le meilleur choix et c'est dur
pour ça que ce choix qui crevait les
yeux depuis ce début a fini par être
fait en dépit d'autres candidats qui ont
été poussés dans le poids de la fidélité
la question elle se poussent pas c'est
aujourd'hui le plus proche des manuels
macron donc devenu ça se défend
du point de vue du poids politique je
serai pas tout à fait d'accord avec
olivier à moitié d'accord c'est vrai que
c'est aujourd'hui c'est déjà énorme jeu
plein essor que je fais dans la moitié
mais c'est à dire que c'est vrai que
c'est au fond celui qui a le plus de
poids politique
mais c'est pas du tout un poids lourd
castanet c'est pas un poids lourd
socialiste qui est passé chez makro
c'était un poids moyen même plutôt un
poids léger socialiste mais le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya si peu de poids
lourds et même si peu de poids moyens
chez emmanuel macron les poids légers d
hier sont doux son de d'hier sont
devenus les poids lourds c'est qui
malgré n'est pas poids lourds le devient
celui des cases honnêtement si vous
regardez dans les sondages dans la
hiérarchie de la popularité
il n'est pas du tout du tout du tout du
tout un poids lourd les poids lourds
s'étaient hulot les poids lourds
s'étaient colons l'aimé s'est jamais été
castaner castaner les gens ne le
connaissent pas donc c'est pas du tout
un poids lourd nous remonter ensuite
l'efficacité
on verra bien c'est un peu tôt pour le
dire lui n'y connais pas grand chose
c'est vrai qu'il a un adjoint entre
guillemets c'est pas exactement ça comme
un secrétaire d'état
wamiz délégués qui connaissent leur
détachement sait plus s'il est oui
il est secrétaire d'état il est même
matériel une s ils les légeoises et son
copain secrétaire d'état juste un point
intéressant jusqu'à présent remise
l'intérieur était le 2 alors oui dans la
hiérarchie ça dans le lord protocole est
de 12,2 deuxièmement au 11e rang fillon
de tabac en mars et s'attend bah oui
mais pourquoi c'est un truc c'est très
très bien c'est un truc non c'est sûr
justement la figure de castanet res que
hamrlik article je sais pas c'est un
handicap puisque de toute façon les
millé choix des menus est vacant depuis
le départ d'avon enfin depuis un an et
le départ du monde des poids lourds du
modem d'avoir des des ministres qui sont
pas nécessairement des poids lourds
politiques
après dans le choix de christophe kasner
frères rejoint c'est ce que disait
olivier duhamel c'est à dire je crois
que dans la peau de l'éventail des
possibles christophe castaner c'est un
élu de terrain qui connaît bien les
électeurs qui quand vous qui raconte
comment il a conquis sa et reconquis sa
circonscription en allant à pied marche
et rencontrer tous ces électeurs et
c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut arrêter
d'avoir passé plusieurs mois à traverser
ça exactement et c'est quelqu'un qui est
et qui connaît qui mine de rien se
connaît bien connais bien le sens mieux
l'opinion je pense qu'un certain nombre
de technocrates du gouvernement et c'est
pour ça c'est important est que pour ça
et sa mission et probablement de faire
le lien avec les collectivités locales
mais relèvent de son ministère et c'est
quand même compliqué aujourd'hui ça
relève plus sur l'oeuvre de jacqueline
des réseaux mais est il ya aussi la
préparation je crois si nous ne serons
pas du renard d'un projet de redécoupage
électoral est déjà pour t'avoir
découpage électoral
ça c'est sûr sur la question déjà que
soulevait alexis ii le manque de
nouveau monde qui trouve un peu ses
limites parce que il ya un peu manque de
personnalité je ne partage absolument
pas l'analyse selon laquelle c'est un
poids lourd ou ce serait une grosse
pointure ou alors elles ont vraiment
réduit c'est c'est pour les castaner
icaunais les électeurs parce qu'il en a
pas n'oublions pas qu'il était la tête
de liste socialiste aux élections
régionales paca qui a fait que la gauche
a dû avoir à choisir entre christian
estrosi et le front national ce qui fait
passer christian estrosi pour un homme
de gauche
alors c'est un cetain est un magicien de
la politique christophe castaner et puis
franchement que t'être de l'historie de
là il était élu à vos qualités il faut
faire du lait mais enfin bon vous avez
marre des pulls des aussi débuté mais
nous savons ce qu'il essaye au ch
donc aujourd'hui bianco l'avait été oui
on se fera donc donc c'est cette non
franchement je trouve que alors plus le
ridicule ne tue pas un homme qui a dit
qu'il était quasiment amoureux des
manuels macron au début c'est un
flagorneur absolue c'est quelqu'un qui
n'a aucun nom mais moi non je veux dire
moi je suis un peu étonné parce que
qu'on ait mis quinze jours à trouver
effectivement ce que disaient aussi
brisé la solution qui s'imposait comme
on a mis une semaine à trouver françois
de rugy qui lui s'est inscrit dans la
longue tradition des écologistes qui de
brice lalonde à nicolas hulot sont
toujours au même poste et les trusts
c'est assez affligeant c'est à dire que
pas dire ça qu'on ne pouvait pas dire on
a mis quinze jours
mais comme ici comme si on avait on
s'était battu
hors nrj mobile et à la fin ça sera
castaner et à la fin c'est gaza ballon
si l'on avait décidé comme ça a été fait
antérieurement pour hulot de se
contenter de remplacer poste pour poste
vous pourriez dire on a mis quinze jours
pour castaner se passe à l'histoire de
abba écouté un exposé qui allie nouveau
non mais vous avez raison c'est toujours
comme ça avec les médias vous installez
vous je termine juste mais nous
attendons un commentaire de milan tout
ça pour ça tout ça pour ça et tout le
monde un homme et répète là elle joue
sans regarder un instant les blessures
les suisses cautionna mais j'avais très
mal un forum sur qu'elle voulait lui
serait bien quand c'est n'est requise en
charge des cultes aussi n'oublions pas
les déclarations grotesque qui l'avait
fait sur les femmes catholiques qui
était voilée
ça veut dire qu'il a acquis aucune
connaissance non plus de ce dossier la
voir bientôt ligue 2 nos mères et voilà
je sais que c'est plutôt inquiétant
c'est plutôt inquiétant c'est quand même
quelqu'un dont vous appelez voilées des
gens qui se contentent de mettre un
foulard est en effet 92 tradition de
mettre la poule a et ça leur est encore
parfois quand on va à la messe ou la
tornade c'est pas dans la rue excusez
nous on n est pas dans les orteils
scolaire alors vous êtes sans doute
nombreux dans tout cas avoir répondu à
la question quand vous posez
êtes vous satisfait de la nomination de
christophe castaner au ministère
l'intérieur nombreuses aides sont peu
plus me fait mentir 72%
j'ai pas vraiment 72 pour ça alors on
l'a dit en face à santés de picoler bien
christophe castaner c'est un choix
associé à laurent niasse qu'on l'a dit
un spécialiste patron du renseignement
des dg ainsi les autres maintenant on va
on va aller à passer un petit peu en
revue si vous voulez bien justement je
pense que c'était pas un choix ce qu'il
n'avait plus le choix
c'est à dire que dans tous les noms
qu'ils on l'a mis sous le nez il n'y
avait pas de personne qu'il avait
suffisamment confiance et donc on ne
viendront danser l'argument de la
confiance qu'il emporte finalement donc
il n'a pas le choix c'était la carte
forcés à laquelle il a fini par se
résoudre mais qui lui crever les yeux
depuis le début c'est plus sympa pas la
contradiction il ya deux minutes si on
met toujours comme idole intérieur le
plus proche le plus loyal et la décision
forcée il n'avait pas le choix et c'est
un peu contre les toits mais parce qu'il
a tenté autre chose et edouard philippe
et anne essayé de lui vendre un coût
d'un major philippe tenter autre chose
et ben c'est pas marrant mais pourquoi
ils sont là
mais quinze jours mais pas que ça mais
pas que ça d'une part il pour vous
casser les trois jours il le savait il a
pris les médias que mozart il a pris la
6e place avec enrouleur il a joué avec
alors qu'avant on va te faire le
remaniement de demain oh non on va
compter c'est un peu plus excitant il a
pendant l'absence et la machine
médiatique avec la viande ça vient de la
jambe
simplement les gens se disent ah ben il
a fallu quinze jours pour cette même
surface à l'import et non mais il faut
que ma position plus centrale dans la
ville a mis quinze jours tout le monde
si on panique s'est aggravée au gré d'un
autre côté c'est aussi un peu difficile
bon christophe castaner d'arrivée et et
de jouer le ministre qui est
indispensable alors qu'effectivement on
a mis quinze jours à trouver cette
solution s'il avait été si indispensable
ça se serait imposé l'équation politique
vaut mon nom 8
c'est pas que tu as tonnerre arrêté 8
mai alors exactement le même profil que
pour celui de gérard collomb on a
l'impression qu'à l'intérieur il faut un
thuriféraire du président c'est un peu
dommage on en parle on l'a dit enfin les
regarder même avec un équilibre alors
sans doute on va commencer par
jacqueline gourault on en parle et qu'il
ya un périmètre élargi avec voilà
jacqueline gourault avec associé à deux
ministres l'un sébastien lecornu l'autre
je viens de normandie
là c'est la prime du modem la labérou
euros non ça malheureux le second tour
non mais le renforcement quand même de
son terrible je pense qu'effectivement
il ya un côté très politicien finalement
très ancien monde dans ce remaniement
c'est qu'il n'ya pas du tout de grands
changements on prend des fidèles du
proche du président et on fait des
petites équipes
un ou deux socialistes et pas mal de
proches de bayrou modem et jacqueline
gros et l'idée derrière c'est de se dire
il faut se réconcilier avec les
collectivités les territoires mais c'est
pas bussereau non plus que c'est pas y'a
pas de voile ah bon
et là je pense que c'est très bien et
fait très bien à faire mais c'est pas ça
il va réconcilier avec les territoires
sur le fond là alexis a raison sur le
caractère tout simplement politique de
ce remaniement est aussi un monde où
vraiment on peut importe si et macron
commencent à comprendre qu'il faut aussi
savoir faire de la politique et donc
donner satisfaction aux modèles de
nidification des gens qui viennent de
redonner cette façon quand et donner
satisfaction aux gens ouverts à droite
et ce qu'il a fait dans les quatre cas
de ce ministère c'est qu'ils commencent
à comprendre l'importance de la
politique ce qui est intéressant
là c'est la question des structures
gouvernementales vous avez deux types de
ministre quand on crée un gouvernement
brésilien seul qui veulent absolument
est très haut dans le protocole pour moi
c'est les crétins puisque ça n'a aucun
intérêt mais il se bat et s'ils sont
deux trois quatre cinq six ou bio
qu'avant ils sont là se pavaner comme un
paon et il se rase le matin avec
beaucoup de bonheur et puis vous avez
ceux qui se contrefichent de l'ordre
mais qui se bat sur l'esprit est rien et
ça c'est autrement plus important est
donc le vrai changement là c'est le
changement des structures qui en effet
enlève à castanet enfin en relève au
ministère de l'intérieur
la tutelle des collectivités locales des
relations avec les politiques de crème
et les demain ce ministère plein alors
on va voir ce que ça donne mais c'est
une tentative intéressante pour se dire
il faut que je structure autrement
l'action publique pour arriver à mieux
non seulement avoir des meilleures
relations avec eux mais à mieux faire
bouger les choses je vous donne la
parole quelques réactions juste quelques
instants joan baez ou suit 15 jours pour
attendre ce remaniement était ce
nécessaire ça ça revient souvent
la fidélité d'accord broker pense comme
les journalistes et pas comme ce que
vous leur donnez pas les faits alors
évidemment pas ce collectif alors qu'un
jour on commence alors et vous dans vos
propos c'est juste leur blabla gros tous
à l'école s'interroge la fidélité
d'accord mais les compétences c'est plus
léger on l'a dit cette le tandem entre
christophe castaner et laurent deux
nièces le lui le encore que laurent ne
s'est pas vraiment un flic c'est un
préfet c'est un oui bon mais pas de trés
apprécié quand même d'abord quand on met
un flic les gens ne sont pas contents
quand on met un gendarme les faits sont
pas contents tant que magistrat un
préfet s'est teinte en soit c'est pas
dur d'après ce qu'il fera bien le boulot
explique lato sensu sais pas il à paris
match un policier il a été préfet dans
territoriales
il a il avait été de l'affairé lizin
passage un service de police dans sept
policiers puis la sicile le
renseignement intérieur un haut
fonctionnaire
monsieur babineau de nice castaner c'est
le choix de la sécurité et continue
castaner est un homme de confiance cela
démontre une certaine fébrilité
c'est trop tôt pour juger si c'est un
bon choix mais il a peu d'expérience et
toujours monsieur babineau qui continue
j'aurais quand même préféré des nouveaux
visages et ça revient aux six et des
troisièmes couteaux enfin tout le tout
ce qu'on évoque sur le côté finalement
il n'y avait pas non plus tonnes de nos
tant que personnalité qu'ils les gardent
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement il n'a pas brillé
il n'a pas brillé lalart le parlement
n'a pas bien réussi à secondes et
l'action du gouvernement c'est pour ça
que se joue est alors très étonnant
parce que il aurait effectivement été un
très bon secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement
il y avait une logique dans cette
ascension là pour me suis pas besoin de
la république revient et risque fort
heureusement savez question n'ai pas
besoin moi je pense que la grande erreur
c'était de se brouiller avec valcke il
ya quelques mois macron a uniquement
émis les valses qui du coup tu leur
donnes ival j'aurais mis si entre temps
ne s'était pas brouiller valff alors
j'imagine l'émission maria bohlin bâle
s'est brisé abbas est ce un nouveau
monde
non
non pas du tout parce qu'il avait plutôt
un bon bilan l'atout prendre le drian
est d'ailleurs macro comme essayer de
décider le drian et boudry a pas voulu
je pense que le drian avait plus de
poids politique je dis pas que ça ferait
meilleur ministre l'intérieur que
caceres ne sait pas encore mais en tout
cas en termes d'incarnation politique
qui pèse plus lourd que castaner bon et
le drian pas voulu ton crestey kastner
qui lui a le grand grand mérite d'être
un fidèle des fidèles des fidèles
joueurs de la question cela sur le
remaniement moi je trouve ça montre un
que macron se contente mais c'était
important de consolider sa majorité
parce que il va pas chercher plus à
droite va chercher des gens de droite
qui était déjà dans sa majorité il va
rechercher des modem qui était parti il
avait qu'il avait lui même fait sortir
du gouvernement et un moment il va
rechercher un peu de socialistes qui
sont des socialistes savent être
compatible avec lui donc il a il a
aujourd'hui qu'on celui de sa majorité
c'est important moi j'ai plutôt
l'impression que pour aller plus loin
dans les réformes
il aurait fallu qu'ils élargissent savas
électorale donc j'ai pas convaincu que
ça change grand chose là dessus
deuxième chose je trouve que c'est un
signe mais plutôt positive pour moi qui
revient sur des principes anciens qui
étaient des pas de politique mais plutôt
des techniques là clairement il allait
chercher il fait un remaniement qui est
politique et je pense que ce qui lui
manquait depuis un an et demi c'était la
politique
et deuxième chose il va rechercher des
centristes qu'ils avaient fait sortir
lui-même donc qui revient sur ses
premières sur sa première philosophie de
conception au gouvernement en 2017 alors
on s'arrête encore sur quelques noms
s'il voulait bien donc on le sait franck
riester tient ministre de la culture qui
vient de la droite agir constructive
voilà mais c'est d'une droite qui depuis
le début soutient emmanuel macron c'est
pas une se dire ça il élargit passons à
ses électeurs n'étaient pas exactement
dans la majorité
mais les habitués vont réagir
domicilié à l'inter de ce groupe il
était du côté de ce qui s'était passé
les plus proches dans l'ue mais je veux
dire il s'est quand même un tout petit
chouia de plus de récupération sur la
droite et didier guillaume qui remplace
stéphane travert à l'agriculture didier
guillaume qui vient du ps et valls east
éloignement de manuel valls qui avait
annoncé en janvier qu'il abandonnait la
politique oui qui avaient pris la ville
voulait perdre le groupe la coupe du
monde de rugby
et puis qui après audio bah non payés
voilà j'en regarde ce que j'ai entendu
j'ai pas vérifié mais c'est très tard
les gens qui font des trucs pas payé et
puis alors en chemin tu as envie d'aller
pas leurs cinq sens bien ici
il est revenu au sénat mais du coup il
n'a pas pu retourner au groupe
socialiste radical et puis paf le voilà
mais c'est sans doute ça compense le
départ de jacques mézard parce que
jacques mézard sénateur du cantal enfin
représenté un interlocuteur important
moi il me sens quand même que ce
remaniement ne permettra sans doute pas
à la réforme constitutionnelle de passer
moi je pense que maintenant
gérard larcher va vraiment faire du
sénat un lieu de d'obstacles à cette
réforme conçue ciel pour ne pas offrir
cette victoire politique à m'accrocher
mais si vous me présentez un remaniement
ministériel dans l'histoire qui est
servi à une révision constitutionnelle
pour qu'elle marche ça n'existe pas ça
non mais mais sur scène je pense que par
rapport à le
un signe qui est envoyé en choisissant
didier guillaume et on remercie
méar donc on fait venir didier guillaume
c'est pour continuer à essayer d'avoir
au sénat où le groupe en marche ne
représente quasiment rien enfin succès
25 sénateurs
non mais y aura besoin au moment du vote
de la réforme constitutionnelle de cette
majorité qualifiée
si le sénat il fait obstacle ça passera
pas mais on sait depuis donc il fera ou
cinq en tout cas un certain nombre de
long qui connaissent la feuille alors
dans votre sol la réforme
institutionnelle on aura le temps d'en
reparler
la finalité de ce remaniement c'était le
second souffle de ce point de vue le
pari qu'est-ce que vous soufflez rayé
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer à la
télévision ce soit faire une allocation
on en est à une 2h30 à 3h qu'est ce que
vous lui soufflerie et pour dire ça y
est on part de ne pas faire de locutions
ce soir je pense que je pense que si
vous voulez depuis je peux ni cet excès
d'honneur ni cette indignité franchement
je trouve je vais pas me répéter mais le
discours tout ça pour ça tout ça pour ça
pour ça a été exagéré parce qu'il ya
quand même des changements huit nouveaux
membres d'une équipe gouvernementale
c'est à rien le fait qu'il ait levé un
dosage politique très calculée comme on
l'a dit c'est pas rien ça prouve qu'ils
comment comprendre l'importance de ces
choses là et en même temps ça ne mérite
pas une allocation pris une allocution
présidentielle parce que c'est pas non
plus quelque chose de très important il
ya 115 heures mais je me suis reprise
savez compter sur vous pour souligner
meilleurs joueurs s'ils délivrent moi je
vois pas vous les trous 7 à 8 nouveaux
cépages huit nouveaux c'est pas lui
entrant dans le gouvernement il y en a
pas vite nouveau on a changé mais
écoutez moi j'ai dit marc fesneau ça
fait deux
franck riester 6 3 laurent d'une hes ça
fait quatre blessés du boss alors si on
n'a pas parlé de dieu voilà gabriel
amard exemples comme ça j'ai hésité les
huit baies gabriel je suis content je
suis d'accord gabriel a témoigné ce qui
me frappe dans tout ce remaniement c'est
que depuis le début de cette émission on
a à peu près par les deux genres
peut-être sera pas hyper connus dont je
pense que j'avais beaucoup oui c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas assez bien ça c'est
intéressant et c'est du monde comme ses
anciens monde vous dira ridicule c'est
entièrement quand il ya des gens qu'on
connaît pas j'ai compris que la consigne
dû ni mosquée blanche quoi que ce soit
il réussit cette thèse
voyez vous le voyez bien bayrou est
parti pour des raisons qui ne colle on
est parti hulot est parti c'est un
groupe quand on compare bonus ne serait
ce qu'au gouvernement de hollande au
gouvernement de sarkozy aux besoins de
jospin avec personnes connaissaient
bancaire personnes julie alors personne
ne l'avait loué la qualité précisément
vous ans et bien je pense que d'engager
la province de québec vous en tant qu à
faire qu'à prendre des inconnus à ce mal
il valait mieux je pense aller au bout
de ce qui avait été engagé je pense que
de ce point de vue c'est une occasion
perdue
je pense qu il fallait continuer
justement ce que vous dites blanc caire
ce belloubet busin la société civile
parce qu'il vaut mieux on peut dire les
politiques se précise il me vaut mieux
des déjà un petit si des civils qui
permettent de de faire venir une
mutation politique que des vieux
politiciens un peu centriste un peu
socialiste demain je vais pas simple
mais on dirait du hollande mais
franchement les calculs on dirait du
holland
la difficulté c'est que ce n'était pas
un cadre bancaire ce qui est pas le cas
de buzeins ce qui n'est pas le cas de
ces deux là la bombe a besoin est
libérer les sondages aujourd'hui sont
par ailleurs le prêt de la société
civile c'est que c'est pas simplement au
gouvernement il fallait aussi et c'est
là où le parlement n'a pas imprimé du
tout là l'espoir que l'élection de
macron avait soulevé c'est
qu'effectivement il y avait une façon
différente de faire de la politique et
la société civile auraient pu s'y
reconnaître le problème c'est qu'elle ne
s'y reconnaît plus et aujourd'hui tout
le monde chante les louanges de jean
michel blanquer
l'air effectivement d'être un ministre
compétent quand vous regarder dans le
détail rien dans la structure du
ministère n'a changé rien dans les
directions du ministère n'a changé nous
sommes quand même pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu le dossier quasiment
au mois de novembre les programmes
changent pour la première l'an prochain
pour la terminale
rien n'est défini sur le nouveau bac
donc on est malgré tout dans beaucoup
d'improvisation et la difficulté car
jean-michel blanquer
c'est qu'en réalité elle était un pur
produit de la superstructure du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
alors il le fait mieux qu'un certain
nombre de ses prédécesseurs qui
effectivement n'y connaissez rien mais
c'est un pur produit de cette nature il
a été professeur de droit alors les
jeunes il était directeur de l'essec
vous caricaturez il a dirigé ce qu il a
été recteur donc le 10/02/2011 nous
caricaturer on a reculé que les produits
de maisons saviez qu'il n'est pas relayé
à l'intérieur de son administration et
permet de monza pour le coup je connais
un peu le dossier il n'est pas relégué
parce qu'il a des blocages
parce que vous avez effectivement haut
niveau par exemple des choix
pédagogiques de l'inspection générale
des hauts fonctionnaires qui freinent
tous les projets du ministre et quand
emmanuel macron avait dit on va faire un
spoil system qui avait choqué et qu'il
ne peut pas faire aussi a ses règles et
voilà ils sont effectivement moi je
crois que jean michel blanquer a quand
même fait beaucoup de choses pour
rattraper les catastrophes qui était
auparavant
mais effectivement pour ceux qui
connaissent le fonctionnement interne du
ministère nous disent qu'ils y seront
six heures tu as énormément de
résistance et que le changement est très
progressif pour répondre à votre
question de savoir si on a un nouveau
souffle
clairement non on a on a à mon sens on a
aujourd'hui une consolidation de la
majorité et donc le gouvernement a
traversé une période de 2 3 qui était
compliqué la lidc on se ressaisit
mais il n'y a pas le nouveau souffle
alors peut-être que l'uimm annuel mâcon
sera donné ce soir son discours mais il
vient pas du remaniement en tant que tel
mais en même temps personne n'attendait
de la zone euro exactement provoquer
l'adhésion faire la collection seul à
quai à la question twitter que nous vous
posions être convaincu par ce
remaniement
guère convaincu à 84% vous répondez non
et enfin enfin je voulais vous donner le
résultat de la question il est donné sur
le côté oui emmanuel macron qui parle à
20h et le côté aussi kippour en marche
maintenant parce que finalement c'est un
peu le parent pauvre de l'histoire un
parent pauvre peut-être en tout cas que
castaner
à plus ou moins fait le job pendant
pendant un an
ça va être compliqué de le remplacer à
la tête dans l'arche l'évier vais bien
d'idées non non je suis pas directeur
des ressources humaines de remarque donc
j'ai pas entendu parler de griveaux mais
ça s'est compliqué toute façon à la tête
dans machete un double problème c'est
que d'abord quelle que soit la personne
qu'on met à l'heure actuelle ne serait
pas connue donc il faut qu'elle se
construise d'une notoriété une
compétence et deuxièmement marche c'est
un objet fluide nous je sais pas trop
quand une amie d'enfance et pas c'est
pas une c'est pas un mouvement politique
structuré et donc le c'est pas de chance
vous reconnaitre on peut fabriquer vos
listes pour les européennes c'est pas
trop difficile de macron leurs vrais
sujets avant ou là comme vous voulez
c'est de structurer un mouvement
politique consistance européenne ça
contrat parce que ça c'est un scrutin
national
si la liste en marche même si elle
arrive en tête mais qu'elle fait 25%
elle répète le score du premier tour
d'emmanuel macron ça veut dire qu'on a
beau élargir à droite à gauche sans
contrôle indique la difficulté elle est
là c'est à dire que arrive un moment où
il ya quand même une sorte d'
objectivité des données et si on a
élargi la majorité où on a consolidé on
termine au score où on était deux ans
auparavant sa pause avant les
européennes je pense que leur stratégie
c'est de miser sur le nom du président
était d'ailleurs assez de nationaliser
la campagne mon avis c'est périlleux et
puis très convaincu par l'argumentaire
nationaliste contre contre le
progressiste qu'il est à mon sens plus
dangereux également mais leur vrai enjeu
électoral c'est de trouver les têtes de
listes ou des ou d'églises dans chacune
des villes où ils vont devoir présenter
des candidats en 2020 etc 2020 c'est
demain et donc il ya un énorme travail à
faire pour en marche de structuration
allez on passe à l'autre sujet politique
du jour les perquisitions menées ce
matin chez jean luc mélenchon et dans
les locaux de la france insoumise ces
perquisitions menées dans le cadre de
deux enquêtes ouvertes sur les
assistants parlementaires et les comptes
de campagne de la france a soumises
aussitôt jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
hésité à dénoncer un jeu site coup de
force politique et ses troupes a appelé
à la résistance regardé c'était ce matin
devant le siège de son parti regardez
écoutez bien et puis on ne serait ce que
vous en pensez
c'est en force comprenant parce que
c'est destiné à nous faire peur et à
m'intimider
pour ce qui me concerne c'est un échec
total ma nature personnelle fait
obstacle à toute intimidation
mais penser aux braves gens qui ont été
réveillés ce matin qui ont des petits à
la maison pour ceux qui en ont et qui
ont vu surgir la force policière armée
pour perquisitionner chez eux
nous sommes des honnêtes gens ne la nous
ne livrons aucun trafic
nous n'avons rien à cacher tout est
public dans ce que nous faisons c'est
une volonté de leur part de nous
intimider de criminaliser notre action
politique
je ne me laisserai pas faire je n'ai pas
peur mes amis n'ont pas peur c'est eux
qui vont avoir peur du retour de bâton
on est encore dans le débat politique
non vraiment je suis extrêmement choqué
par cette vidéo que j'avais pas vu je
suis choqué par la vidéo que j'ai vu ce
matin
six films et où je cite il explique ma
personne et sacré je suis parlementaire
il enfile son écharpe en exemple pour
vous terminez bien de bien comprendre
qui je suis je n'ai peur de personne
nous nous sommes honnêtes vous et c'est
un discours d'abord complètement mégalo
s'il n'était pas en démocratie
de démocratie dans un état de droit jean
luc mélenchon aurait jamais plus fumer
avec les policiers qui le tour quand
même ce que diddy qui les visent entre
autres le regardent ça sera plus simple
c'est effectivement la vidéo qu'a posté
jean luc mélenchon il s'est filmé
pendant la perquisition que vous me
trouvez une drôle de tête c'est parce
que j'ai fait l'objet d'une perquisition
depuis 7 heures du matin chez moi ainsi
qu'au siège du parti le parti de gauche
s'il vous plaît dit partout que ceci est
naturellement un acte politique me
touchez pas monsieur vous n'avez pas le
droit de me toucher
ça c'est trop dur heures tandis que je
sais pas quoi
personne ne me touche ma personne est
sacrée je suis parlementaire et pour
vous en convaincre et que vous terminez
de bien comprendre qui je suis mais moi
ça voilà
chez moi mélenchon ont souri mais on se
dit qu'à moitié
non alors que moi je trouve son discours
extrêmement dangereux il ya eu
l'impression dans la soute les français
ensemble de tension il joue et on a
quelqu'un là qui avec une boîte
d'allumettes dans une grange plein de
payet qui s'excitent à savoir quand
est-ce que ça va péter
donc je trouve que ce discours est pas
responsable pour un élu politique en
plus et mégalomaniaques et on a qu'ils
soient victimes d'une perquisition
j'imagine que c'est pas agréable soit
heures du matin il me semblait que ça
vous même à intervenir dès 6 heures
c'est sûrement pas agréable mais c'est
une poignée une procédure judiciaire il
pourra faire valoir ses droits comme il
doit déjà les faire valoir avec ses
avocats
tout ça est un montage médiatique
voudrait une pointe pour se placer à une
posture de victimisation populiste qui
me semblait ne pas être très sympa scène
du tout pour un fonctionnement de la
démocratie victimisation pas celle du
tout de la piste du tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée nationale au moment des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement il
a fait un très bon numéro ça vraiment
ils méritent césar d'honneur pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière qui serait
crédible s'il avait fait la même chose
pour ce qui se passe au venezuela où là
ya pas de perquisition mais on passe les
opposants par la fenêtre quand ils sont
dans les commissariats de police
et moi je me souviens de l'attitude
absolument indigne de jean luc mélenchon
face à laurence debré dans l'émission
politique où il avait été d'une muflerie
absolument incroyable alors qu'on était
en train de parler d'une quelque chose
qui est dramatique 6 face au vu de cela
donc jean luc mélenchon serait crédible
si la vue la même indignation pour ce
qui se passait dans des pays qu'ils
considèrent un peu des modèles la thèse
du complot politique elle est un peu
éculé alexis écoutez moi je suis partagé
cet adage
évidemment il en fait des tonnes il en
faut dix kilos il joue à la vie mais
tout ce qu'on aimerait évidemment ils
jouent avec le feu je pense que dans
certaines mesures si la justice joue
avec le feu dans tous ces dossiers il
faut bien qu'on est quand même dans une
situation aujourd'hui où on peut se
retrouver avec marine le pen interdit de
faire de la politique de main coup ci
soit 17,2
d'assistants parlementaires mélenchon
est allé faire la boutique demain
françois de facto pour la même raison et
a interdit aujourd'hui de faire de la
politique
et s'il n'a pas été ministre il n'est
même pas envisageable qu'il soit
ministre c'est parce qu il sait que si
depuis qu'il est depuis qu'il a
démissionné bayrou il n'a pas eu
pas plus que mélenchon avant lui puisque
marine le pen a remis un coup de fil
d'un policier lui a demandé de venir de
s'expliquer etc
mais il sait que le jour où il est nommé
ministre s'il était nommé ministre le
lendemain ils auraient droit au grand
machin
ça pose quand même ça pose quand même
souvent des questions sur cette sortie
c'est ce que je crois pas je pense pas
du tout que ça le pouvoir mais je dis
qu'on est on est on est quand même dans
une situation où la justice est en train
pour des bonnes ou mauvaises raisons
cette histoire d'acide d'attaché
parlements de six temps parlementaire
sans doute c'est pas légal mais qui est
en train de faire le tri dans les gens
qui dans ce pays ont le droit de faire
de la politique ou pas de faire de la
petite si à la fin des fins et je
défends pas jean-luc mélenchon je
défends pas moi je défends même pas bon
ça bayrou mais si à la fin des fins on
se retrouve et que c'est tous ces
acteurs là qui sont des acteurs
importants qui représentent quelque
chose qui sont interdits de politique il
ya quand même quelque chose qui qui qui
qui fonctionne pas qui va pas olivier tu
es un mec je sens que vous avez plein de
choses à répondre oh non non vous sentez
pas juste là ou non parce que j'ai pas
dû dire la même chose que tout le monde
sauf peut-être ce qu'a dit alexis à la
fin je ne connais pas très bien dossier
donc je ne sais pas s'il y avait des
motifs impérieux affaires perquisitions
se sont jamais compris moi pourquoi
comment des gens qu'on accusait de
quelque chose ça pouvait être utile
trois mois près de faire une
perquisition chez eux de me baï qui a
des cas où il ya des gens qui gardent
quand même des choses comme moi je sais
que dès qu'on l'a déjà fait moi je suis
donc le fait pas venir pour leur
demander que brzezinski sa police ya
l'idée de perquisitionner chez moi je me
débarrasse immédiatement il reste
toujours un truc de tout ce qui pourrait
être gênant jeu parce que si quand même
lui rendent un service immense il faut
bien voir que ces vidéos connaît
convient de regarder elle vous choque
elle nous choque il ya énormément
jean qu'elle choque pas il ya énormément
de gens qui ce qui choque c'est qu'on
aille perquisitionné chez le mélenchon
est ça le hir ruiz talons elle utilise
et le héros is donc il faut de sérieux
motifs pour prendre des risques
politiques comme cela et voilà ce qui
fait que je suis partagé ce qu'il fait
et ce que je dis d'un outil qu'amateur
pas du tout jamais à double benno dit
c'est quand même étrange ça tombe sur
mélenchon le pen fillon mais ça ne tombe
jamais sur la république en marche
étrange étrange bonnie tout de suite on
pense à nicole je n'ai pas entendu
mélenchon quand ils se sont attaqués à
fillon puis à le pen quand c'est la
droite c'est pas grave mais quand c'est
eux une suspension
monsieur babineau qui est très présent
ce soir à l'image de marine le pen je
trouve que mélenchon instrumentalise la
justice à des fins politiciennes sur le
précédent s'est pas complètement vrai
repas ce que mélenchon s'était insurgé
contre la décision le pen c'est là on va
peut-être regarder les images avec les
séries à l'assemblée fillon le fait
qu'il se soit rien passé depuis
l'élection parce que c'est pas normal
c'est que pendant 3 prendre trois mois
il ya un acte par jour parce que
l'élection dans huit mois qu'il se passe
plus rien mais je dirai moment ou bien
c'est très grave il faut il faut avancer
ou bien c'est parce que c'était
peut-être pas la peine d'en faire un par
jour on sent qu'il ya je crois pas moi
la supplantation il ya quelqu'un dans le
bourg et brun publie manitou dead mais
il y a des emballements et des
ralentissements et des comportements
judiciaire qui quand même à tout le
moins se prête à recommander le citoyen
lambda c'est donc la cible un monsieur
babineau tout ce qu'il nous dit ce qui
est surprenant c'est le timing quand
même perquisition le même jour du grand
remaniement s'interrogeait en même temps
ça pollue aussi un petit peu le
remaniement donc c'est à double
tranchant
photo image là pour reparler du fn est
reine et de la france a soumis quand
jean luc mélenchon parlé cet après midi
à l'assemblée les bancs de rassemblement
national
applaudissez on va le voir
donc voilà effectivement les élus du
front national applaudir aux propos de
mélenchon
il a perdu son titre de meilleur
opposant emmanuel macron sur l'épilation
c'est difficile à dire monsieur lang or
le problème c'est que macron réussit pas
mais l'opposition est dans un état
encore plus enfin les oppositions sont
dans un état encore plus lamentable
moi je suis plutôt inquiet cette fois-ci
simplement comme citoyen justement de
cette déliquescence je pense que
l'élection de macron représenter la
promesse d'une recomposition qui a
beaucoup de j'allais dire de déception
du fait que cette recomposition ne n'est
pas en train de s'opérer et en même
temps qu aucune alternative n'est en
train de se construire
me semble-t-il enfin c'est comme ça que
je l'interprète vraiment je me place ici
comme le citoyen lambda essayant de le
plus stupéfiant quand même parce que il
est devenu si faible qu on en parle plus
mais c'est la déliquescence du parti
socialiste le fait que le nouveau leader
quasi inexistante parvient même pas à
avoir une parole écoutée
le fait que le parti de la gauche
important du parti socialiste soit par
tu sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
que donc benoît hamon a quitté le parti
socialiste manuel valls a quitté le
parti socialiste emmanuel maurel et
marie noëlle lienemann quitte le parti
se sel dit guillaume dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et qui devient ministre
et quitter le parti socialiste
de tous les côtés c'est la débandade qui
d'un parti qui a été un des principaux
partis en france depuis un siècle
mais c'est vrai que sur ses ruines je
rejoins ce que dit bono glisse en ligne
macro n'arrivent pas à reconstruire
quelque chose dit à l'héroïne on les
voit bien mais il n'arrive pas c'est
parce que c'est pas possible tout ce que
vous dites est profondément juste mais
c'est probablement lié au fait que le
champ dévasté est encore plus vastes
comme le croire dit une permettre
dévasté bahsoun excusé c'est l'ensemble
du politique en ce moment
me temime est rongée par mélange de
désenchantement hydrojets c'est presque
au delà des partis c'est pour ça aussi
que bon peut-être qu'il ya une peut-être
évidemment macron à des incapacités des
défauts des rentes et de déceptions n'y
a pas de doute mais ça va au delà des
incapacités de macron c'est regarder ce
qui se passe
même dans les autres pays regardez je
suis pas très très vite regardez le
breakbeat derrière le parti porteur du
brésil
you keep fondu regardez en maille
regarder bon c'est au-delà jeu de
l'incapacité vraiment très important
parce que quand vous regardez tous les
pays l'italie l'espagne l'allemagne
l'angleterre partout vous avez un
éclatement les grands partis
gouvernement sont complètement fissurée
ces fonds je pense pour ça que macro en
fait c'est une étape de décomposition
pas lui lui mais ce que son élection
représente est tout simplement parce que
là il faut effectivement nous observons
la vie politique au jour le jour mais
fois un peu de recul je pense que tout
simplement les sociétés européennes sont
en train de payer très cher ce qu'on a
appelé la grande récession ce qu'on
appelle la grande récession et qui en
france a été en partie amortie mais
c'est une crise économique je pense que
les événements à partir de 2008
il faut un décalage dans le temps et
quand vous regardez les systèmes
électoraux il se dérègle entre 2012 et
2015 dans l'ensemble des pays aux
reprises de cela n'aide pas que cela
parce que cela un autre acteur il ya
chaque fois fait planter contre la
corruption regardez le brésil c'est la
corruption
et quand un parti qu'on croyait qu'on
croyait propres alors partie de travail
au brésil c'est frappant mais même en
italie le parti démocrate pour part en
france il ya eu dans les années 70 80 le
parti socialiste qui a été atteint la
corruption ces ravageurs c'est le
facteur avec ce que vous dites c'est le
second facteur qui détruit sa croyance
en la passant civilisé
global qui est de 2 pieds de
déclassement des sociétés européennes
par rapport aux émergents et à
l'intérieur des sociétés européennes
entre une minorité qui est de plus en
plus riches et l'asca qui utilise un
port ide et et tout ça a crevé par
l'immigration fatou tout ça fait système
est une force politique nouvelle ne peut
régénérer c'est ça qu'elle ne fera donc
le la colère les partout et elle prend
des vecteurs divers médecins eux-mêmes
macron était un des vecteurs de cette
colère oui thierry henry sait plus trop
quoi en faire parce que qu'est-ce qu'on
devait partir de la colère et quand jean
luc mélenchon et c'est mi5 leur écharpe
tricolore parle de maquereaux et de sa
bande de petits ministre ça nage ou
peut-être pas mes doigts sont pas là
mélenchon a le même problème que le
présent macron cette assemblée elle a
été élue avec 42 % de participation aux
élections législatives une assemblée où
il ya 58 % d'abstention et 42%
c'est une assemblée qui de toute façon
est forcément extrêmement fragile et
l'élection présentielle à elle seule ne
peut pas entraîner le sel ou alors
carrément faisons dans la réforme
constitutionnelle une proposition que
l'élection législative et a lieu le même
jour que l'élection présidentielle et
auquel campdoras un vote politique et il
y aura une participation supplémentaire
mais si on continue à avoir une sorte de
pensée magique où on a un homme
providentiel qui surgissent d'on ne sait
où parce qu en fait un homme
providentiel
normalement il doit avoir un passé macro
n'en n'avait pas c'est d'ailleurs
c'était sa chance au sein et une
assemblée aussi fragile le système ne
peut pas fonctionner quelle que soit les
talents du présent macron que je ne
sous-estiment pas du tout alors va
passer à une autre facette de la
présidence macron elle est peut-être
beaucoup plus légère est anecdotique
c'est une femme de l'ombre et qu'il est
longtemps resté au point qu'il n'y avait
quasiment pas de photos d'elle
il s'agit de michel marchand dit mimi
patronne de l' agence de photos best-
images qui alimentent la presse pipole
alors ces trophées et par exemple la
photo du couple macron un maillot de
bain à l'été 2016 en plein lancement de
la campagne
avant cela il y avait eu celle de
nicolas sarkozy et carla bruni à
disneyland à et bien d'autres encore
mimine marchand est aussi devenue la
conseillère en image officieuse de
brigitte macron au point de se rendre
tous les jeudis en tout cas elle l'a
fait pendant près d'un an à l'elysée
pour une réunion de cabinet un livre
dans kate sort sur l demain
dont l'un des auteurs jean michel
décugis ce journaliste est interviewé
était interviewé ce matin dans le figaro
il fait notamment le parallèle entre me
marchand et alexandre benalla on va voir
ses propos à l'écran tous deux dit il
prospère à la frontière de l'officiel et
du privé ils marchent main dans la main
ce que l'un s'occupant d'assurer la
sécurité l'autre de donner la meilleure
image possible de la présidence notre
enquête montre aussi qu'au plus fort de
la crise benalla mini marchand n'était
jamais bien loin bref cette ce goût
c'est du goût pour des macron pour le
transgressif alexis brézet cette
présence à l'expérience et à faire je
pense que c'est d'abord déjà le goût de
l'efficacité me merchat a presque tout
le monde raconte et quelqu'un
d'absolument essentiel dans la gestion
de l'image des people est aujourd'hui de
plus en plus la politique c'est une
question d'image de c est ça devient un
les la communication politique s'inscrit
dans les codes de la communication des
people et c'est vrai que les macron
peut-être parce qu'il la connaissait et
puis parce qu'il faisait vendre sont
devenus
un des bons clients enfin des bons
sujets pour les paparazzi dont voilà
donc tout ça tout ça très très bien à
tous a très bien marché je pense pas au
départ c'est pas une relation d'amitié
de toujours c'est simplement que chacun
fait avec les photos des macros et les
maquereaux il se fonde la popularité à
bon compte sur cette espèce de deux
manson politique de déclin des parties
des idéologies de on regarde les jambes
et les jeunes ils sont sympas puis à
cette histoire
il est jeune elle elle et moi c'est
incroyable et donc ça fait une histoire
formidable pour la presse people et ça a
compté dans l'élection de macron c'est
absolument évident après qu'ils aient
souligné c'est le mélange déjà passé
pour que l'état pour vendre ces photos
caser ses photographes c'est quand même
tout petit peu choquant mais je sais pas
et cette photo très franchement la photo
qu'on voyait à l'instant on va la
repasser fait quand il voudra victoire
est décédé juste après l'élection c'est
invraisemblable dans le bureau élyséen
manque de alors après elle a expliqué
qu'elle passait sur la photo elle elle
même contrôlée à calais elle est laissée
l'arroseur arrosé parce qu'elle s'est
fait voler cette photo ce qui a été
ensuite diffusée qu'il n'avait pas
vocation à être publié
un peu c'est nous qu'on allait princesse
un mélange déjà vous pas olivier sur le
côté à la fois jeu sur le tableau presse
people et puis en même temps je serai
encore au moins 1000 odieux que alexis
donc elle gagne à être connu elle a un
passé assez non mais j'ai rien contre du
tour très présente et là moi quand vous
voulez ya aucun problème on peut dîner à
trois ce n'est pas ça la question
mais mélange des gens mais qu'ils ne
mélangent pas si vous avez une agence de
com et que vous travaillez pour un
politique un président un premier
ministre un ministre
jamais encore les meetings de la
présidence macron les journalistes se
sont fait un peu mettre au pas on a eu
cette histoire de liste qui avait été
faite par l'elysée pour dire voile en
veux tu être journaliste pour nous
accompagner sur têt déplacement et pas
d'autres
la salle de presse est à bron tout ça et
là plus que les photographes 2000
marchands qui ont le droit de faire des
parcours qui vendent aux faux journaux
choisis parmi les marchands l'as monaco
là ne peut qu il arrive
comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver à
empêcher des photographes des poules
physiquement on en revient donc à mon
fait mais ici les temps si les savoyards
pain si vous avez sous la porte et qui
passait des photos les indiens à sa
règle ses frères hilton vient
déplacement est ce qu'on va être dans
l'hélico est ce qu'on va être sur le
truc est ce qu'on va pas fière et là il
ya le pool qui à droite dans le pool ça
c'est des négociations auxquelles on
participe tous les jours mais quand au
bout du compte il n'y a pas de pouls il
n'y a pas de photos et puis il ya
toujours le gars de lagence 2000
marchand qui va la vendre au journal feu
on se dit ah bah tiens c'est bizarre
pour toi aussi le monopole qui
critiquent et celle instrumentalisation
à des fins personnelles voilà d'une
communication qui devrait une pression
au public d'accord belge apprend mini
logis voyez-vous des eaux de vie a très
vite pensez vous que milly marchand
spécialiste de la presse people soit
trop présente à l'elysée c'était la
question que vous posez vous êtes 78% à
trouver que oui alors peut-être que vous
connaissez mieux me marchand qu'il n'y
paraît blueberry cake nous dit notamment
marketing storytelling pipolisation et
une fonction qui n'est plus qu'une
coquille vide
c'est son avis w la communication peut
servir à gagner une élection n'est pas à
gérer un pays et nicole s'interroge la
presse people ne devrait pas avoir ses
entrées à l'elysée où va-t-on erwan nord
vous ne voudrez pas encore exprimé sur
cette grave question exactement mais je
suis pas non plus un très grand
spécialiste de cette grave question je
crois que un point clé
rappeler c'est que me marchand a
commencé à travailler je crois avec le
couple macro pour valoriser leur image
mais aussi pour la contrôler parce que
au sens où la rectifier parce qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de rumeurs qui
étaient répandues sur les manuels macron
et ce qu'elle sait faire visiblement
c'est empêcher les mauvais les des
rumeurs se diffuser la cité sur sa vie
sexuelle et donc ce que l'idylle
d'ailleurs votre interview c'est que ce
que raconte l'auteur sait que l'épousé
d'emmanuel macro est allé la chercher
pour le dire il faut voir il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter ces rumeurs qui
diffuse partout et ça visiblement elle
sait le faire
moi ça me choque pas que prénom la
république est quelqu'un à côté lui
qu'il aide à contrôler son image parce
qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus
effectivement après mais j'ai pas lu le
livre j'ai pas vu les détails donc
savoir comment est-ce qu'elle utilise
éventuellement cette position spécifique
pour s'enrichir jeu de ces le sujet là
évidemment ça pose un savoureux plus de
questions je suis pas non plus
spécialiste de milieux marchand pas
encore et bien vous pouvez le tissier de
le devenir en lisant donc ce livre ni me
paru chez qui sort demain chez grasset
merci en tout cas beaucoup à tous les
quatre et puis ben rendez vous demain
pour un nouveau point de vue présentée
par guillaume roquette
[Musique]